it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we revealed the cultural
stories of the week and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
all right Raymond I know you're excited
about this but Prince Harry he's
appearing in court this week wow Laura
hyari is locked in a legal dispute with
a tabloid that he claims tapped his
phone between 1996 and 2011. now the
Tabloid denies those claims well this
week Harry became the first Royal to
appear in court law since 1891. only
cameras weren't allowed so a British
News Network hired an actor to recreate
his testimony I believe that again as a
child every single one of these articles
played an important role a destructive
role in my growing up unfortunately
stories that you've only that I've only
shared with one or two people within my
inner circle ends up front page of
newspaper or any page your circle of
friends starts to shrink and diminish
rather rapidly
abuse Court sketches and a voice over
Laura I mean though with Prince Harry
I'm surprised they didn't hire Nicholas
Holt or some a-lister to play him yeah
that was wasn't a very convincing acting
job there Raymond I mean he had the hair
kind of right but he he kind of looked
like that actor from Modern Family a
little bit he didn't but but if if
Prince Harry is so concerned about
public exposure stop writing books about
your family and doing Netflix
documentaries I mean that's one way to
stop it you know this is like the
stripper who complains about public
exposure that's what you do so I mean
more books yeah they said no more books
about the family okay anyway speaking of
books as a best-selling book by a former
child actress Laura it's called I'm glad
my mom died well in a New York Magazine
interview talk show host and child
actress Drew Barrymore seems to agree
with the sentiment of that book she says
of her friends quote all their moms are
gone and my mom's not and I'm like well
I don't have that luxury but I cannot
wait now why brace yourself Drew
Barrymore took to Instagram this week to
try to clear things up
[Music]
to all your tabloids out there you have
been with my life since I was 13 years
old I have never said that I wish my
mother was dead how dare you put those
words in my mouth I have been vulnerable
and tried to figure out a very difficult
painful relationship while admitting it
is difficult to do while a parent is
alive
are you following that Laura I I did I
didn't even know that was Drew Barrymore
she didn't I didn't even know that was
she but I prefer her when she has her
that's the at-home Edition yeah when she
has her hands above her head and she was
screaming for E.T I preferred that Drew
Barrymore she was well you know the
problem with this is I mean she clearly
is saying until a parent is dead when
you have this kind of complex
relationship you can't heal but it
sounds like you're you're begging for
the death of your mother and I'm sorry
therapy should be confined to the
therapist's room not broadcast for
everybody to see and hear and I realized
she's had a lot of trauma she and her
you know her mother was taking her to
clubs at eight years old she was in
rehab at 13. so I get it but this is not
the way to deal with these issues and
certainly it's not a broadly held
experience anyway finally Laura I have
another raise rule for travel beware of
novel redesigns of aircraft Interiors I
give view the in-flight double decker
put your legs up and recline stretching
your legs fully forward taking advantage
of the double decker and allowing for
the person you're on top of you to also
recline and not in major personal space
now Laura I want to point out a
stranger's butt is in your face now
imagine that it's that lady we talked
about a few weeks ago who was asking the
airlines to accommodate her you remember
her she said the aisles were too small
if you hit turbulence this flight could
be all over I mean you could take out
several rows behind you I also hate the
idea of having the wall in front of you
in this design it's like flying in the
toilet with a low roof I don't know I
want this but speaking of the air
speaking of the airline toilets have you
noticed that they're now so small the
sink is kind of a little tiny triangle
like you can't I can't even get one
digit into the sink to wash it I want
they're so tiny I don't know how people
even fit I can barely fit in there well
they're getting so small pretty soon the
commode will be the only place to do
your business and wash your hands
they'll be nowhere else I don't know
what they're trying to do it'll be
comfortable it'll be an interesting
summer Raymond invariably we will have
to travel for this show and we will have
more travel nightmares and horror
stories to share with the audience at
large Raymond great double adapters for
us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else